pleased to have here on the program as
promised uh the
the new film uh is called honest thief
and it's available next week uh on
friday
october 16th and it's also available in
theaters wherever theaters are open it's
a new action thriller
starring uh liam neeson and my next
guest
who is also uh his work we all enjoyed
in suicide squad and other
great films jai courtney is here on the
rich island show how are you jai
hey what's up how you guys going we're
doing fine we're doing absolutely fine
where have i found you
right now where are you i'm in los
angeles okay yeah i'm out here i've been
out here all year i live out here these
days so
uh okay i've been i've been uh you know
holding down the fort in la
uh through the through the madness of
2020.
okay very good so um what's
what sports do you follow whether it's
from your native australia
or out here in the united states which
which which do you
uh get into i've always well i i used to
play rugby league uh growing up and
that's still what i'm i'm
most plugged into i still watch the uh
the rugby competition back home
it's a little little inconvenient
because most of the kickoff times are
like
two or three a.m but i managed to get
around enough but it's actually the
business end of the season down there at
the moment they've got the finals coming
up over the next couple weeks so it's
getting very exciting well aussies
though have met out here in los angeles
uh
jai um who are either rugby fans or
like yourself have uh dabbled uh in it
look at american football and think uh
these guys in pads and helmets think
they have it tough
uh are you one of those gents soft core
man i mean
come on it's soft i love it i've heard
that so
you you feel that way huh nah look i
think i mean look it's an amazing game i
don't know too much about uh
about american football i've been to a
few games and uh it's a lot of fun to
watch
it's crazy you know what's crazy to me
is like the stop start that's the thing
that i'm always like i feel like these
dudes are such
like amazing athletes but they never get
to run around for more than a couple of
seconds man
that's right i mean you know that's
right what's it like uh
in a scrum what's it like what's it like
in a scrum it's very smelly
and uh yeah mostly that's that's what i
remember most
that's the sensation yeah that's of all
the senses of all the senses
touch feel all that yeah you smell
getting squeezed between the cheeks with
two other guys that's pretty much
okay is there anything uh in the acting
world that's similar to that
at all oh man you have so many
similarities
come to think of it oh my gosh i'm sure
uh all right so let's talk about uh your
and you ufc have you uh have you tried
that
are you are you into uh
the mma yeah i love that i'm a big i'm a
big ufc fan and
i get around that a lot as a spectator
here in the states that's probably what
i uh
probably what i digest the most i love
mixed martial arts and
um you have enormous respect for the the
athletes
uh in that world of sport for sure so
who's your fighter who you follow who
you're like okay i will definitely get
the fight for
for this person i love a man i get them
all i get all the pay-per-views i don't
miss a beat i love it i literally live
for it
i'm planning at the moment there's a big
fight coming up on
uh october 24 khabib number made of and
justin gaichi i'm already i was just
sitting in my kitchen this morning
drawing up my
my schedule for the the brisket i'm
gonna cook that day and like
planning that whole thing out around it
so uh it's a big deal for me i love that
stuff
so um how long does it take for you to
submit your brisket
well this one's only about five pounds
so i'm looking at about a
probably a six hour cook um
with some rest time on top of that yeah
it's a slow
you know it's just a it's a slow
submission victory that i'll be uh i'll
be winning over this one
by the way that wouldn't be a bad chris
brockman fantasy football team named
ner nerga nurmagomedov's brisket
that wouldn't that wouldn't be bad he's
a real
bear that guy nurmagomedov that guy is
amazing amazing amazing
i would be very frightened of that i
mean did coach didn't honestly didn't he
wrestle bears in like
uh in belarus or wherever he's from or
something like that
that is serious business yeah i've seen
those videos too yeah
i wouldn't last two seconds in the in
the cage with any of those guys they're
savages
so again so literally that's what you do
you you plan out
um your your evening and your cooking
based around the years
i like i like to cook and i like to you
know i have a couple friends around
obviously these days it's a little
different but
i don't care i'll throw myself a little
party and uh and cook all day
getting around that sort of stuff it's
like i like being festive and i love
having the sort of
a big sporting event with high stakes
there's nothing better than
than getting around that watching all
the lead-up material you know
even your buddies i mean back home
that's the cool thing these days i got
my
you know my close close friends back
home that i grew up with with still
we can engage on the same stuff you know
you have boys on facetime or
you know you're texting all day with the
live results and uh
and you know analyzing everything
thinking you know better than what's
going on on the screen it's a lot of fun
i'm here with jai courtney uh on the
rich eisen show let's let's talk about
your career your filmography right here
so many people
are uh familiar with your work and um
suicide squad is captain boomerang how
did you get involved how did you get
hooked up with that
with suicide squad um well the first one
we did was about
what was that 2015 so a few years ago
now um
i just got involved the uh director on
the first movie david ayer called me up
and
um yes you know they needed uh they
needed a
a an bags to come in and play that role
and you fit the bill is that what you're
saying apparently i i was top of the
list somehow
okay uh so uh i didn't i didn't even i
didn't balk at that opportunity that was
sure i gotta say that role has been one
of my most fulfilling
personally because uh i don't know
there's kind of no limits to it i just
get to have fun and um
you know and and and not act too heroic
or uh
you know trying to indulge in any
redeeming qualities he's um
he's kind of a a bit of a despicable
dude and that's a lot of fun to play
i like playing bad guys man it's it's uh
it's good fun that way it keeps things a
little lighter you get a little more
freedom to kind of
mess up and and um you know be unlikable
in a way that audiences want more that's
always the challenge well not to get too
deep here but you seem like a nice guy
to me john why do you
why does that appeal to you i mean
what's going on i think
you know i've done i've done a few
movies now and and you know
look it's if you can play an earnest
character with
real kind of depth and uh and kind of
contrast and a bit of
vulnerability like that's always uh you
know
challenging for an actor as well and and
you know if your part's written well
then that's
great stuff to kind of get involved with
and sink your teeth into but um
i don't know bad guys are a lot of fun
man i've been in some some great big
action movies where i sure have
i've uh i've i've played kind of pretty
terrible people and
i always walk away having a good time no
i mean jay i mean you've been around
you've been around some uh we want to
talk about action
film action film stars as well i mean
with jack reacher tom cruise
uh a good day to die hard you were uh
john mcclane's son jack and bruce willis
right there
we can keep going on and i will uh you
got arnold schwarzenegger as well from
terminator genesis
and now your current film uh honest
thief with liam
neeson who literally is the last person
you'd want to be in a fight with out of
all of them
literally i don't know they're all kind
of they all damage me in different ways
i don't
liam keeps it pretty tight man i mean
that's he's a big strapping lad he's uh
he's still throwing down pretty hard um
i don't know yeah
i mean he's got hands dude the guy's got
hands what do you mean he's got hands
what do you mean he's got like right now
you're like what do you mean you got
hands
he died he did throw hands did he sound
bomb okay
okay all right and then what about bruce
what about i mean arnold too i mean
arnold you don't want to mess with him
bruce you just can't kill i mean arnold
you don't mess with he's
a human uh so you don't even go there i
mean tom's flying out of airplanes every
other day
riding motorcycles off cliffs so uh you
know
he's the last guy i'd want to have chase
and me but um i don't know man i've been
i've been privileged to learn a lot from
these guys and
and and be around it and sort of suck up
that
atmosphere and and what's inspiring to
me is you know the longevity of these
careers i love
uh i love seeing these guys you know
still doing what they love but
you know a little ripened more ripened
age and uh
and it's awesome it's inspiring to to an
actualized member all right it's a
current
fb you're a corrupt fbi agent in an
honest thief
um so do you want to give me your
american voice here and
is there a way for you to like how did
you learn that sort of thing
what my accent stuff oh man i mean we
yeah we got to do that
all the time that's the way it goes in
the business if you can't kind of
if you can't get the work done early and
show up and try and do a kind of
convincing
uh character in that sense then uh i
don't know then you're in the wrong
you're in the wrong business but um i
i've had great voice training the whole
time i always rely on great you know
acting uh accent coaches and
right uh i mean what do you channel who
do you channel when you're
you're doing an american accent jack
because it's you know i enjoy listening
to you right now
the the uh i don't know the character
i'm playing you know i think it's like
it's i stay in it that's kind of a
secret for me
personally right some actors well you
know we all have our process but um
i find it more easily like kind of
easier it's easier to kind of keep an
accuracy a level of accuracy that feels
authentic
if i just live in that voice for the day
and sometimes it's hard to shake off
because i'll go home and i'm
you know you don't drop it you're like
you're ordering a pizza and you're still
talking the american accent
but i've been out here a few years now
man i mean my exposure is pretty
uh pretty full-on i've been living in
the states for about eight years so
i'm kind of in and around it a lot and
um i don't know i try to have a good
year and
and just try and work hard that's the
main thing and and that's you know do
the best job you can
well again honest thief is available um
next week
on friday october 16th and in theaters
where theaters are open
john i appreciate the time let's let's
chat maybe uh when you're getting that
brisket ready
you can uh you can tweet it for the next
fight
you know you can give us what we'll send
out the jai courtney
recipe i mean i think let's let's let's
uh
basically what i'm saying is this is not
uh goodbye it's just farewell how does
that sound okay
thanks rich that sounds great to me
pleasure talking to you right back at
you that's jai courtney right here on
the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here